okay you multiply both sides by 70 you
get some number over there on the right
hand side and then you turn to a
calculator and you go you press shift
sign and then off it goes right you get
an angle out right now once you get that
angle though you have a problem because
that might not be the answer there's
another answer that could possibly be
does anyone is this jog your memory now
what's this call this has a name this
problem you should turn the write this
down as to make this this is called the
ambiguous case if someone got their
calculator there can someone actually
tell me what angle when your mischief
side can you tell me what angle you get
like a once what's the site just use
degree is fine I don't care of it so
good shift side of 75 44 degrees on 56
it feed the cream 16 just like when some
decimal after that 15 minutes okay so
we'll go without 60 degrees okay yeah
the thing is it might not be 60 degrees
it might not be 60 degrees it could
actually also be 120 degrees right so
the ambiguous case is that this is
ambiguity as to which angle is which
okay now how many of you know why
there's an insecurity here like why
can't it be 120 degrees okay so you can
talk you can make an argument from
quadrants because you learn something
about like all stations to central data
lit up but do you ever the point of a
machine is like graphing right graphing
is a super power I know you look at this
in you wince a little bit okay but the
graph of sine just tells you really
obviously why this has to be the case
what is the graph of sine look like do
you have a picture in your mind you're
like someone's his side and you're like
ha that's what it is this is what you
always jump into your mind right now
when you get 75 44 5679 4460 i assume is
thing like theirs so it must be
something like that whatever that value
is point 84.7 I have no real idea okay
you can see what you're solving when you
say sign of your angle equals point 7 or
poirier is where do these two lines
intersect you see this is a graph
movement everything right and clearly
there are two points where these graphs
intersect there's 60 then and then
there's the some 120 affair now knowing
the graph well just makes that really
obvious of course there is an ambiguous
case right and conversely of course
there's no ambiguous case for clothes I
right when you use the cosine rule
because what is the graph of the cosine
like have you have your own picture your
mind okay it's kind of like that reverse
Bell Kofi now when you look at this the
angles in your triangle right angles in
a triangle I from no point in your
fluidity okay well your angle is not
going to be over here right if you're
getting some positive number over here
if you get an angle over here there's no
ambiguity right if I draw a life here or
here or here or here between not and 180
you'll only ever intersect once there's
no I be doing you'll always know exactly
what the right anyways which is why you
should always use the cosine rule if you
have a choice okay now why why always
use the cosine rule if you have a choice
because something's are talking because
you're ready in a textbook no because
you know what the graph looks like
you're back impels you toward one rather
than the other so all of this stuff that
you're going to invest in now to work on
these graphs trust me it's worth it u14
the P have a look at this I've got a
whole bunch of examples some of them are
kind of put them in order of difficulty
/ the central miss but I really want to
get through and bringing them as we
possibly can so I've been stalling